[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
buddy a very special episode of
leftovers we have a live feed of
Mar-A-Lago as we await president Trump
to be arrested for what why would you
play crickets
ladies and gentlemen the tensions are
high the attention is palpable the
tensions are high in Mar-A-Lago we are
outside of Mar-A-Lago right now
the atmosphere is dense you can almost
cut it with a knife you can hear the
Crickets folks
you can tell that the people are very
excited
to defend Donald Trump there was
supposed to be a human moat outside of
Mar-A-Lago created by the proud boys but
turns out that uh they are no longer
there uh hold on Hassan is that a but is
that a body uh a person moving perhaps
behind that palm tree there is it it
sure seems like it's a bit of emotion
sure seems like there's one guy with a
ladder walking around back there but it
doesn't seem to be uh the federal agents
nor does it seem to be Trump supporters
it seems like landscapers do we know who
that is for certain do we have do we
have any way of figuring out maybe any
boots on the ground we can get some
intelligence what's the activity going
on here that we see no because much like
the Donald Trump supporters we also only
sent one stable camera crew over to
Mar-A-Lago instead of an actual reporter
the helicopter is enroute and we'll get
a live feed from that coming up oh my
God Donald Trump uh doing a O.J Simpson
style Bronco slow pace Chase would be so
sick that would be awesome oh God yeah
so um
any minute now we expect the feds to
come raiding in and uh taking Donald
Trump in for uh processing isn't it
that's right folks The Matrix is very
much coming for Donald Trump for the
crime of saving the white race if you
can can you uh can you full screen the
Mar-A-Lago uh once again yeah so if
you'll notice it seems it seems to be a
bit of a cloudy day how do you think
that this kind of adverse weather could
affect the raid
Ethan uh the federal agents seem to be
working rain or shine like the U.S
Postal Service when their target is
a man who is once again I'm repeating
myself defended the white race the white
hope the white savior the FBI wants to
absolutely end this man's career and
this man's political aspirations because
they are terrified that he will be
saving America once again I love it yes
if you notice the flag the old bring it
back up please the American flag that
looks like a solid I don't know I'd say
15 miles per hour so there's going to be
some interference from the elements here
are is there some kind of rain gear that
they could be attaching to the SWAT uh
equipment uh how what how are they
prepared for this kind of weather
this is literally this is the
conversation stuff unfortunately
unfortunately as you know Ethan the
police have been severely defunded even
in the red state of Ron DeSantis that's
right the police have been defunded
completely and therefore have zero
tactical anti-rain combat gear here in
Florida uh we have a donation Link in
the bottom of our screens if you would
like to donate a new Cruiser or a
stinger missile to the Florida police
department or the FBI uh you can make a
charitable donation uh right down there
and below in the in the description box
thank you and could you pull up the feed
again please yeah so if we take a close
look here could it is it possible that
the federal federal agents could be
making a water landing have we seen
anything like that before well this is
Florida Ethan so of course they do have
those very cool boats you know the ones
with the big propellers in the back oh
yeah the fans for for gator hunting sure
yeah yeah yeah they might be utilizing
that uh in a very tactical fashion when
they inevitably come and arrest
president Donald Trump uh let me break
in for just a moment I have uh
unconfirmed reports that the FBI agents
that will be raiding
um in lieu of the poor weather have
obtained FBI raincoats they have rain
proof coats wow the FBI now uh again
this is unconfirmed and Dan can you tell
me is this a new technology that they've
developed how long have the FBI been
wearing these types of wrinkles this is
from a program that uh was launched in
1996 it cost 48 billion dollars to
develop these jackets
um from the look of it worth every penny
I would say we're not every penny and
those are are those weather resistant or
waterproof do you know again these are
unconfirmed reports but
my sources tell me that it is weather
resistance not proof
it may get a little wet you may get a
little damp out there right
well they are very demoralized as you
guys know because uh you know our
wonderful boys in the blue we've been
we've been talking a lot of [__] about
them so right you know it's it's really
hard it's really hard to be a cop it is
it's one of the most dangerous jobs in
America Hassan the most dangerous I
would say yeah can we get the live
feedback up please
and so uh no that's Dan oh sorry
and so yeah if you could full screen it
oh my God
and so do we know uh the dynamic between
uh president Trump's Secret Service and
the federal can you pull I can't do this
if I don't see Mar-A-Lago
oh
sorry we're all a little we're nerves
are jumpy here today this is a big day
if you're in the control room Ian's a
little caught up guard here so so if the
um the Secret Service or see her service
are clashing with the federal agents I
wonder what kind of uh unexpected events
we can see from that Hassan even
depending on uh how Donald Trump feels
about the Secret Service on any
particular day is how I'm going to
change my commentary if they are
defending Donald Trump in a Waco style
tactical scenario then I will be on
board with the Secret Service not being
at the behest of the secret pedophile
Democratic party cabal if they end up
handing Donald Trump over to the
authorities then they of course have
been compromised by the Democratic
party's secret pedophile cabal that is
interesting I've heard Whispers
well we'll keep you guys updated of
course uh the live feed should be on the
screen at all times in case there's any
uh activity
big news welcome Hassan nice to see you
Corey Welcome to The Leftovers great to
be here on this wonderful day is it
speaking of rain it hasn't stopped
raining in Los Angeles and I'm losing my
mind it's actually I think if it's not
it's close to the most rainy stop you're
on record for us stop it no I'm serious
stop it yeah okay we're all we're almost
like
93 of the state is out of drought now if
I if I wanted to live in a bum ass City
I'd live in Seattle okay if I wanted to
live in you know if I wanted to live in
constant rain like what is the I feel
like this is like we're approaching
England territory yeah it's been it's
been pretty yeah let me look at the
weather yeah top of the [__] morning
yeah
oh Cheerio he's [__] gray out here
Lads yeah I hate it Hassan
there's more rain coming up man we
needed it oh I hate that I hate whenever
someone says
we needed it my house is gonna burn down
this year what
yeah you don't care about that your
house is not going to burn down this
fire season
okay well good I mean so great that's a
plus yeah but also about that but also
my feelings uh and I my feelings of
sadness because I work out outside and I
just oh it's the worst dude you wake up
at six a.m and you gotta go outside and
it's [__] raining there was a tornado
yesterday yeah maybe you're right
there's a tornado Waits everywhere tens
20s
what do you mean I know you had a little
hunk yesterday on the broadcast yeah I
actually got to um
I don't know what it is but I need to
take a [__]
I don't know what it is if it's the
coffee or what
breaking news breaking news
I'm so sorry to do this guys this is
there is the plus and minuses okay well
I'm gonna I'm gonna go through I'm gonna
go through some of these things go ahead
I'll be in the bathroom okay any
activity happens at Mar-A-Lago uh just
shout okay go pick in the door
immediately thank you guys I'll be right
back all right well I was watching I was
watching Ethan's uh uh conversation
yesterday with the tick tock guy who is
like uh
who I've actually covered on my YouTube
as well uh in my Andrew Tay wannabes
their hilarious series uh Sebastian uh
you know Romania's proudest Soldier
right and I remember him I recall him
saying something along the lines of in
one of his tick tocks like I could
change Ethan's life like just give me
give me a moment with him and and it was
wonderful to see Ethan's life change
yeah let me think on camera alone
that was that was truly truly brilliant
I feel like for all of uh for all of
Ethan's like faults and there are many
of them be real
for all of his uh you know for his
inability to control his uh worse urges
of uh you know blurting out whatever
random nonsensical thing that's going to
land him in trouble uh by uh a a
designated hate Watcher audience that's
like waiting to clip [__]
um he is in his element whenever he's
doing whenever he's doing these kinds of
uh interviews he's very good at like uh
slowly but surely you know releasing
more and more of the pressure Until It
ultimately comes to a boiling point
where
uh you know he just leaves his
interlocutors befuddled
and it's always is always a treat to
watch I would say yeah it was a lot of
fun now I thought he did an excellent
job and like you said by the end of it
that he could not wait to get out of
here
um yeah and I was before he even
realized it was live which was an
interesting little twist on all of it I
don't know how he didn't know it was
live all you had to do was look up
anything about the show
okay I have questions though I have
questions because I don't know if you
guys address this maybe you addressed in
the earlier part of the interview that I
missed but
did we ever find out he has a real
podcast because my speculation was that
they do a fake podcast like they make it
seem like they're doing a podcast just
so they can get clip uh Tick Tock Clips
out of it that is really interesting
because I looked for his podcast and all
I could find oh my God I'm right oh my
God I'm right then maybe partially
because I could not find what that clip
of him talking [__] about Ethan was
wrong they don't have it okay that's my
but even if it's not really like sort of
podcast like content on his main Channel
but it didn't look like the same set or
anything even if it's not real even if
it's not real even if it does have a
podcast I don't want to believe it okay
let's just go I think it's way funnier
to think that he just doesn't have a
real podcast and he just does like a
fake podcast
to just get Tick-Tock Clips out of it
because they saw that like you know on
Tick Tock it pops off when you when you
have like podcast Clips so they decided
like yeah [__] having like a full-blown
podcast let's just do a let's do tick
lock Clips
um he has these long form videos like
struggles of growing up poor featuring
my mom let me think about it that you
know is an hour long it looks fairly POG
casty but it's not like an official it's
just content on his YouTube channel how
the [__] does he have 890
000 subscribers wait what he's 890 000
subscribers
my man's getting like 30 000 views
that's crazy pretty wild that he uh
tried to bring up like Ethan falling off
when yeah I know what's going on that's
the funniest part about it is that like
you know obviously fat man bad yeah
everybody knows that well that was his
first point out of the game clearly no
you just gotta you and you gotta the
more you say it the the more real it
gets yeah like I've I've noticed that
like the more you repeat that like well
you're a fat person and therefore you're
like uh immoral
um the the more the more valid it became
for me at least
um
but the one thing that I always find
funny I briefly alluded to this last
week when I was talking about like Ethan
being more Trad than like 98 of the
conservative commentary circuit having
like multiple children and a wife you
know what I mean been in a steady
relationship for years yeah located
monogamous relationship yeah yeah like
actually actually real Trad [__] right
[Music]
um the other part of it is like for all
these Alpha Bros for the shrigma grind
set you know wake up get my cake up uh
dudes out there he also has like a
successful like a profoundly successful
business like multiple at this point so
right I was thinking about that a lot
when I was watching the the conversation
take place and it in my mind I was
thinking like dude you don't have a real
podcast this guy does you're trying to
make it on like you know uh on social
media this dude has for many many years
now right okay not to like glaze up
Ethan all that much I'll when it comes
back from the [__] I'll start making
fun of him yeah no like we said so many
flaws line interrupt real quick he's in
chat right now and he's saying someone
tell Dan I'm typing under the podcast
account uh oh I see I'm a Trad King yes
uh oh I see that he said uh this is a
spicy one okay he might not be back for
a while from one oh
yeah add that to the list yeah his this
is what happens when you [__] eat
frozen pizza all the time Jesus Christ
okay so but as I was saying he's a
successful uh you know he's a successful
podcasting business right uh he's a
successful content business these guys
want to make that happen for themselves
he also has uh like like an actual uh
with Ila like an actual [__] fashion
merchandising brand right no they just
drop shipped their clothes but but like
but like you can't you're doing all this
same [__] that like you're trying to do
the watered down down shittier version
of what this dude is doing
simultaneously being like you're a
[__] loser it just like doesn't why
would anybody look up to you while he's
like trying to uh yeah obtain everything
that Ethan has like
that's I don't know I mean a lot of a
lot of uh people like that a lot of
their fan base is like super young so
they only see like shapes and sizes you
know
they can't like they can't comprehend
anything beyond that very effective
counter to all of that because I'm like
well I'm bigger than you like I can you
know what I mean I I yeah it helps I
work out I promote a a positive healthy
lifestyle of physical fitness improving
Your Mind Body Soul you know uh all the
time
so what's up what do you got and at that
point it just basically is reduced to
well you also like defend uh you know
marginalized groups and I don't like
that right because that's always what it
is it doesn't matter what uh Ethan is uh
saying or doing clearly it's just like
you have a difference in opinion you're
toxic because you're defending the
rights of marginalized people so you're
a bad guy for that Ethan says I don't
eat frozen pizza [__] ass classes
I can't even read that how about how
about he say that to my face oh wait he
can't because he's stuck on the [__] as
his [__] [__] is just pouring lava
right now
he said uh just a moment ago that uh he
said uh this is bad it's just sent that
message in the chat so
good stuff it's gonna close it's going
well it's going well in there it sounds
like
yeah yeah
wiping is optional yeah
I don't know about that I guess there
was a brief stutter we know chat uh
don't worry uh yeah it's just the one
weekend's all good I was just looking at
that but yeah it was uh it was it was
fun it was fun to watch uh I especially
appreciated the moment where at the end
like the final culmination where uh you
know you did the the left-handed thing
oh yeah like you hit him with the so
what's up like uh you know you know that
there's like you've seen the graph of
like left-handed people skyrocketing all
of a sudden when we no longer were
forcing people to be right-handed and he
was just like uh uh like I loved I loved
that moment where you have that clip you
can you pull that clip it's on the
subreddit uh of the of the tick tock
that a fan made
yeah we'll pull that up right now I'm
all right
personally because
um like he was like oh I haven't
investigated this matter like oh I
haven't looked into this and I was
thinking to myself like [__]
you've looked into nothing like what do
you mean you're talking uh you're
talking about a whole lot of other [__]
that you don't know anything about
either like this isn't new let me think
about it hold on well we're pretty sure
uh I mean he basically said right that
his the extent of his research was
watching a handful of like YouTube
shorts uh yeah
um from
Ethan Klein hater account you sent it I
don't know how to pull it up I don't
have like uh oh I can pull it up yeah
that's what I was saying like yeah you
want to pull it up and show it yeah I'm
getting comfortable here it's just like
I'm I'm asking you guys to pull [__] up
yeah yeah go ahead I'll pull out oh
happily Jamie for you all right here we
go I tweeted that because people think
they're born gay and I don't think
they're born gay the amount of
left-handed people back in the day was
really low because people with
left-handed were seen as inferior and
they were forced to use the right hand
more often but as it became more
acceptable then the amount of
left-handed people increased and it
became steady at what like 12 would you
say people choose to be left-handed
yeah you don't know you don't know
anything about anything like you don't
know anything about anything you're
talking about the other [__] that you
don't know anything about why don't you
talk about this too right all right
let's keep going to be attracted to
women yes no I wouldn't say so right
yeah I don't think I I I'm just
naturally attracted to women right
so do I need to connect
oh this music is [__] copyright
unfortunately oh no really yeah
that's crazy it's because it's like on
all of these videos and someone needs to
make Funk like the the this uh style
this genre but the copyright free
version so we can use that on all of our
tick tocks we have a lot of talented uh
musicians in the audience yeah if
anybody wants to someone needs to get on
there we need some Sigma grind set music
that we can use on the show but
basically like yeah the the idea it
doesn't even click
yeah you can even click for him he just
like doesn't get it trying to think but
nothing happens
he doesn't get anything
um yeah he came after my boy uh uh Bryce
so that's why what Bryce Hall yeah oh
yeah that's my as friend of the show
Bryce Hall yeah what what's his beef
with Bryce um I think he was just like
he was doing the classic thing that like
uh you know people who are right wing or
right-wing adjacent love doing where
they're like oh you advocate for like
gay rights uh you're doing it for fake
reasons
um you know what I mean like he was just
like Bryce is the type of dude who just
like agrees with everything that like
people are saying you know what I mean
like and I think it was like uh alluding
to the fact that he like well I guess
sometimes say like
nice things about the LGBT community
civil rights icon Bryce Hall give it up
everybody I I don't even
but
but basically but basically like he was
mad about that and I was just like first
of all I got I got extra upset because
[__] you're like you're trying
to do Bryce Hall like you're a dollar
store but I saw it with that [__]
[__] boy haircut that's why I was
surprised to hear you say that I thought
they were yeah you know he would like
him you know stay in your [__] Lane
dog chill don't come after my mans is
this um is this the video a b that you
just sent yeah yeah here let's take a
look at that Bryce Hall thing that I
that's why I said he's an NPC girls are
saying like I need therapy in the
comments and this dude Bryce Hall is
just like he wants to say and be
whatever the world wants him to be is
gonna say whatever all the girls are
saying so that all the girls can agree
with him and follow him because his
attention is a bunch of little girls
who's just saying what they were all
saying just like regurgitating that like
if Bryce Hall was here right now
he would agree with that for sure that's
just the honest truth yeah I think I've
actually met him before in L.A or was it
Taylor holder I think I met him yeah
yeah and I won't say anything else I
don't want to say anything else damn
what oh spill the tea dude what you got
dude I saw that and it made my [__]
bloodborne okay I thought to myself you
[__] you I'm not boiling better not
come after my man's like that [__] up
you know somebody asked does Bryce Hall
have a Lamborghini no he he also has a
can actually
oh yeah which is like kind of lame yeah
like broke boy what the [__] what the
[__] driving around in a freaking take
hand dude what are you gay you care
about these loser what you got an
electric vehicle lame yeah yeah but that
Porsche is way better than that Italian
trash piece of [__] Lambo
I have okay I have no I have no
experience with Lamborghinis other than
the the Urus
and uh honestly
I love driving my car yeah I think it's
amazing Salada it's a lot of fun to
drive oh my God we have a live feed all
right breaking news
area man caught stuck in the toy
[Music]
toy we have more updates from wait Ethan
Klein business owner
stuck in the bathroom having a hard time
wiping folks
this is on the street this is what the
this is what the podcast and the
broadcast has turned into
oh wait a minute wait a minute oh big
news breaking news wait a minute a live
feed of the toilet
I'm hearing reports that Ethan Klein has
finally made it outside of the bathroom
and it's back in the studio
it's great to be back I was of course
watching the live feed from the bathroom
I appreciate all the kind words you guys
said about me uh
me up and reaching me around which I
appreciate I don't know what the [__] I
did mention that you have a lot of
issues too I heard that part but I chose
not to register right okay yeah just
making sure you didn't miss that I also
I have an exciting announcement
the toilet didn't close the poop
successfully yeah
although I will say I had a moment of
thinking that uh oh this isn't gonna go
down did you wipe
well seeing as it's option typing is
optional yeah Zach I did wipe but I know
it's optional that's my choice given to
me by God so you did what song what do
you do I mean what do I think about why
I solved it but like no it's not
optional you have to watch no but yeah
see you're not you're not hearing the
question correctly
is it optional let them curves of like
life or death
yes okay like life or dead you have to
wipe you have to wipe whatever the
question is that you'll why you have to
wipe your ass or you will die
what do you what no you will die if you
don't wipe your ass what okay the
thought says he gets it yeah
big news you will die if you do not like
your ass yes 100 I fully believe that
look I'm not even I'm not even joking
that's like you're you're describing
like 14th century uh Europe and why uh
[__] eviscerated out there but they
live to like 40. it's not a bit
that's a full happy life yeah no no shot
anyway uh thank you guys yeah I saw you
guys were talking about my boy Sebastian
and since we're on the topic should we
show some of his coping tweets all right
Ethan sure let's do it
um I mean we already you guys already
touched so well on the topic he's went
straight to Twitter to cope and seeth
for example look at some of the ones he
retweeted David you're a lazy [__] with
the American flag Emoji watching this
attempted hit pace of a podcast at C
bass g16 should be called Attack Of The
Nerds oh [__] you handled yourself very
very well while deflecting personal
attacks from the fatty oh
he came away
tweeted that dog attack of the North
this is what he this is what he was in a
rush to go do remember how he yeah he
had a lot to do it was the run to people
you don't like to see past g16 you're
genuinely only playing yourself one of
the best young men I know that's fine I
mean at least he didn't call me a fatty
and a nerd which is the worst thing you
can just call someone dude dude I mean
fat man bad I just want to be like
Batman bad
Batman bad yeah absolutely after that
whole conversation he's like nah he's
right fatty this fatty nerd got no place
to talk to me about anything God bless
sea bass G the man paved the way dude
what oh he went on a [__] oh he did
one of those things where he just like
retweeted everyone praising him like all
yeah 12 people yes that he could find
yes right he paved the way he handed
himself so but then let's go down to
what he said about it himself my
favorite being wait there was 43 000
people watching
I mean he loved
that that's the first time he said like
Real views and not like that Tai Lopez
botted [__] you know what I mean like
AdSense paid
views he says here comes Ethan's fan
base to clown on me I was actually
trying to find common ground with him
but he wasn't trying to have it I
thought he was doing a great job when he
said like you're fat and a loser and
your podcast is in Decline I thought
that that was like really good for
for common ground he's like he goes okay
being gay is a choice let's discuss and
that was on the ground I was I was
thinking preach king that's what I
thought right thank you yeah my favorite
ones under the Buzz Lightyear one
if you scroll down Buzz Lightyear right
Buzz Lightyear right at the bottom of
this one the very bottom yeah oh here
under that one under this one yes right
here every single one of these houses
where is the one that you like in
relation to the buzz yeah if there's any
other ones in relation to Buzz Lightyear
let me think about like three above come
on that was a good marker yeah that's a
big ass picture no you're right you're
right you're right
Ethan I gain weight because I'm on
antidepressants there's barely any
calories in the tablets law he [__]
got you you got you this must be an
eight-year-old he he [__] got you no
that's genuinely that is a Twitter blue
user clearly okay fair enough there are
clearly 48 years old and trying to make
it in the crypto World okay right this
man this man in the Drop Shipping Empire
but I've never actually heard that take
that people you're gaining weights from
anti-person because the calories and the
pills or so that's brilliant I've never
heard that no that's actually that's
brilliant it's novel to be honest I like
antidepressants I think more people
should try it I'm on them right now Seb
are you depressed right now no what the
[__] is this guy even saying wait but
oh he's cut off he's confused yeah no
they're working dude that's why it's
great are you depressed right now no
they're working great
yeah but he I think he's basically
saying like if you're fat there's no way
you can't be depressed like that's what
he's saying I think which is what I
don't understand because like
like the likelihood that every single
person is calling you a fat and and
therefore a loser like statistically
speaking if they're in America like
there's very high likelihood that
they're fat
oh yeah like so I don't really
understand where that's coming from
either he was liking this tweet as well
which I love personally yeah go hit the
geminon yeah anyone that says Anon
anyone that says Anon
uh should you know I'm not gonna say
what I truly feel I'm just gonna say say
it in a parable in Minecraft you should
no you can't say it in a Minecraft
anymore
in a story and I probably shouldn't say
it in a store no no I wasn't even gonna
say anything that bad I was just like I
mean you should go to jail honestly you
should go to jail you're you're [__]
your entire PC should be seized by the
federal government and thoroughly okay
like it's just you're immediately
signaling to everyone that you are a
pathetic [__] loser is this one
edited I can never tell because people
started [__] with these photos so
much I don't think so because like it's
like man that is bro that is a crazy
[__] picture of me dude I mean it
became a huge meme on the show because I
know I know but they tell me dirty like
that I can't tell which one is edited
and which one isn't
uh yeah there it is though I look
comfortable okay so but but finally I
think this is where I hope you realize
that like you should take my advice and
and get on T immediately and start doing
steroids okay yeah yeah yeah and and get
shredded oh because it would shut them
up because like it would be really good
because like here's the thing for a lot
of these [__] losers
like it doesn't really matter what you
look like obviously Nico's been calling
me a [__] snow soy boy like Non-Stop
and it's like dude like he
I I would eat you for breakfast and I
wouldn't get enough protein out of that
you know what I mean like you are it
looks like it was 150 pounds you're a
twink and there's nothing wrong with
that you're gonna make a couple you're a
very pretty twink but let's be real like
come on
um but even then they still do that like
he finds like yeah yeah but my point is
like when he says [__] like that even
his fan base is like
you know they're like oh is this is this
real is this is this working
I don't know if it works so because they
look at like shapes and colors I would
love it man there's a blizzard brain if
you got shredded it would be great do it
out of do it out of spite so should I
get on steroids before and then start
lifting what does that let's link you up
with Bradley I just want a good start I
just want to get on the tee baby the T
Train no I mean I don't know if oh God
you be that button crazy no that button
would never disappear no that button
would never work like
oh God you would get banned if you were
on if you were on steroids you would
definitely get banned oh I see you get
angry and say some unhinged [__] yeah
yeah I don't need it I got the button
now I don't know anymore do you feel
like your life changed yesterday
of my life yeah was it a life-changing
experience for you
it was I went home
I had dinner
but my kids hung out with the kids I
mean if I think about the impact on my
life
they had a life-changing [__] earlier I
did just yeah
does that count is that what he meant I
think so I think this dude's gonna have
probably need some recovery time to be
honest his life might have changed if
anyone's life has changed these glasses
have changed my life hopefully he's on a
different path now I said that after
yesterday's episode he's going to wind
up on antidepressants
when there's nothing wrong with that you
know there's nothing wrong with it in
fact
[Music]
I love I love the notion of being like I
want to come on your podcast and then
you know spending the second half of the
podcast saying I just want to be left
alone that was one of the funniest
things I was like wait what does that
mean I just want to be left alone yeah
just leave me alone man how it started
I'm Gonna Change Your Life how's it
going I just want to be left alone I
just want to be left alone
yeah I just don't understand what's
wrong with your brain that you are so
good in like the most awkward scenarios
but if there's nothing awkward going on
you have to [__] pop off and say some
[__] like it's like you're like I guess
I needed to be awkward one way or the
other so if it's not them well you're
such a Smooth Operator when like you're
just eviscerating the person in front of
you in like
but but then when there is no such
situation you're like I gotta say
someone in [__] I gotta be the awkward
one yeah it's a different um that's a
suited up Ethan
yeah what I mean that's your favorite
Ethan oh that's your favorite Ethan okay
yeah dude it's awesome you just uh thank
you you know you're just very
effectively uh dismantle your
interlocutor to be fair he's not like
the sharpest debate uh no but no but but
like it's not like the the conversation
is supposed to be
like one that is educational you know
what I mean it's it's I'm saying like
it's fun
and you do a good job thank you so much
the other guy I mean the cult guy the
Nexium uh called guy he was he was at
least like somewhat intelligent yeah
that guy got it bad though he was he was
he was good on rhetoric at least that
was a bit of a gotcha I think maybe was
that a gotcha because he didn't know I
had Tourette's I don't know oh that was
definitely a God yeah we got you I mean
the pool first he thought you were
sympathetic to him for half of the
interview yeah that was okay
it was like another hour after the
reveal that you were arguing with him
and uh you you still did well when
you're in that mode as well so I mean
all all I like to do it's almost like
the Socratic method when I talked to
someone like Sebastian I just when I
hear something that sounds funny to me
you want to just dig down as far as
possible and get to the root of like
what does it mean and why do you believe
that
and you know when you get down to below
the surface because guys like that
they'll say something like um
um
you know
being gay is a choice you know something
like that and you can just have a
question which is true I mean yeah
that's what I believe in after yesterday
I didn't believe it before but now I
believe it I'm deciding today to suck
dick exclusively
you know throughout the breaking news
breaking news
but it's a question that uh everyone
should ask others if that's the case
like okay let's say being gay is a
choice what now
why is that a problem well if they think
being right the only it's not but let's
say it is why is that an issue if people
believe being gay is a choice that
implies
that they have some inherent
understanding of that they are having to
choose
to be attracted to women they could
choose they like the option of being gay
right they would choose that but it's
not the right thing to do so they choose
to be women because that's because
that's virtuous to be straight yeah like
Rick Perry no it is a little gay in a
sense to say
being gay is a choice yeah Rick Perry
Rick Perry he once famously said
um you know
dicks are like alcohol to an alcoholic
you know when you're when you've gone
sober I mean he didn't say it like that
I'm paraphrasing but he basically he
basically said something along the lines
of like you know an alcoholic who's uh
you know who who went sober will see
alcohol and The Temptations of alcohol
but we'll avoid it and that's what
homosexuals should do and I was thinking
like yep God damn Rick Perry like every
time he sees like a [__] twink staff
member he's probably like he's like an
alcoholic he's like white knuckling oh
yeah oh god
oh one of yeah one of the good examples
is he says I don't want my woman to
dress with her cleavage out and so it's
a you know you gotta dig deep and
understand okay if he's in a circle
where he's talking to people and friends
and peers they're just going to take
that at face value we say why do you
feel that way why do you feel that way
how does that make you feel like explain
to me why and you know he'll he'll
finally come to the conclusion that
she's his right and so you come to a
Moment of Truth there by digging to the
and it's also deeply insecure too like
it's it's it's paired up with like uh
obviously uh hyper misogyny uh hyper
misogyny meets uh deep insecurity yes
deep deep you know what I mean like oh
this is my property and also on top of
that I am terrified of other men looking
at her and uh her getting some
gratification out of that because
ultimately I think what if she finds
someone that's better than me she's yeah
exactly exactly yeah uh can you can we
take a look at Mar-A-Lago please it's
been a minute since we checked in
Mar-A-Lago of course we are looking
today that's right Florida a cloudy
overcast day with some slight wind do we
see anybody on the lawn any moment now
any moment now Rhonda santis is gonna
come in
with his pretty little boots
and boots is Pretty Little Boots and and
show up on scene you defend oh there it
is a a Rhonda santis has hit the
building folks
watch out Trump he's coming for you it
seems he's walking his pretty little
boots over to the morrow Lago is that
like is that a pool is that a lake is
that the ocean I don't know I believe
it's probably the ocean okay
or some kind of runoff yeah
um by the way this these these memes are
so good there was 43 000 people watching
yeah and then there's uh he used to be
funny he said the thing and then there's
like I also don't worry begging for
validation there's a lot of pictures of
him Dr Weiner to Ethan the whole time
get ahold of this guy 24 yard insecurity
I people don't even know watch you he's
got that verified baby oh we got that
yellow baby be gold like that uh yeah
this one this one is this one is great
the yeah
I heard I actually watched your reaction
I was curious you you were you were
tickled by who the [__] Jimmy Lee was
yeah I didn't understand what was going
on there yeah yeah he's uh he's an
interesting dude yeah
he started to go off the rails a little
bit when he was like well I read him I
saw yeah like my Dad read something that
said gays come from Bad homes yeah yeah
they're fatherless families I was like
Jimmy we're doing so good today
that's like is that is I don't know what
his Vibes are he's gonna get a good beat
on him he's old-timey he's an old-timey
comic that's sort of in our orbit and um
there's a lot of these yeah the Apple
thing was really good when you were like
oh well what Teddy fresh is doing and
Drop Shipping is the same
which but then he also claimed Teddy
fresh was a scam which would imply Drop
Shipping is a scam
selling iPhones is a scam like yeah I
think you're I think you're counter to
like our iPhones the scam was good uh
there was there was a lot of good
moments in there I mean he he had uh
and I mean at least mine is like pretty
flat but that is I love the slide
whistle Zach that was right on thank you
thank you you were going down like the
Titanic brother
that is rough
ly hold on yeah so yeah my analytics are
down because I haven't posted comments
you know what I think happened if I have
to guess and of course it's just an
assumption he doesn't know anything
about me except like the keemstar
talking points I think he probably no he
is just like every other like young kid
who watched your like sketches and
whatnot right and then and then like
probably was uh like maybe thought oh
the podcast is like I'll tune in every
now and then liked it
and and now thinks you're like a like a
woke sjw so he hates you
oh you just stopped watching yes but the
only thing he knows about me is keemstar
talking about I think when I tweeted at
him keemstar has like H3 notifications
on obviously and uh I think he reached
out to him I was like yo bro you gotta
hit him up about fake Teddy fresh rip
off designs and yeah I mean he didn't
know what he was talking about just
looked like an idiot so shout out to
keemstar for the uh for the layout
assuming I I don't know but here it is
it's just a thought I had on the
internet so I just wanted to take a step
back that's why they're down
tough being out there as a Creator huh I
don't think you're gonna make it you
just if you have thin skin like that I
mean that's why it's going down I think
it'll be fine you'll be fine I think
it'll be fine Ethan if I can interact in
his behalf I think he's going to do
better than all of us together oh thank
you Jimmy not not you and me him him
yeah Sebastian yeah but I I I I that's
just my opinion our podcast is always as
continually I don't know who that guy is
he's like one of the characters right in
the world he's a dentist he's like a
[__] millionaire wait what really
he's very successful bro there is a zero
shot I'm letting that guy anywhere near
my [__] face with like anesthesia no
really he's a really accomplished
dentist he owns like six packs yeah but
I'll tell you this the Jimmy Lee iceberg
is probably one of the becoming one of
the deepest yeah my history with him
goes back like I don't know it's almost
10 years now bro that that's wild yeah
people get their teeth done by that dude
so let's let's actually talk about the
news if we can uh so Trump arrest watch
what's going on they what they were
supposed to arrest him on Tuesday they
said that uh they canceled the grand
jury on Tuesday first for a reason they
didn't specify what do you think is
happening and is Trump going to be
arrested
um I don't know like I actually don't
know because the grand jury keeps saying
like uh oh we're not gonna We're Not
Gonna convene today we're not gonna do
it today and then they're like we're
gonna do it tomorrow and then tomorrow
comes around and they're like just
kidding we're not gonna do it today now
there's a couple different things here
to address
one Donald Trump is is a criminal I mean
he's done a lot of crimes he is Mr crime
and like
and obviously uh there's two different
uh perspectives here like all presidents
have done war crimes straight up there
is not a single president you can point
to in the United States of America's
history that hasn't engaged in either
questionable moral Behavior
or just outright you know things that
you would consider war crimes
or other kinds of crimes but of course
that's still within like the the bounds
of Reason even if it is overall immoral
and Donald Trump has done plenty of
those things as well but this is a
unique predicament because Donald Trump
is so Brazen with his uh criminal
conduct
uh and also uh you know he's like a he's
like a New York real estate developer so
he's done like New York real estate
developer type crimes yeah like paying
hush money right uh getting your lawyer
who literally went to prison for this
okay to pay hush money to a porn star uh
and and then uh you know refunding it
through campaign contributions like
that's illegal it's just you know pretty
cut and dry across the board it's so
illegal the guy working for him went to
jail for this okay right
um so now they've they've elevated it oh
and who he went to he was sentenced to
what like 12 years but he got out
already yeah he already got out uh
friend of the show Michael Cohen I've
been on his podcast before did you know
that I didn't yeah he's a friend of the
show I love how he just flipped he's
like bro I'll just be I'll be whatever
you want just yeah and I'll do okay
whatever you want he's a he's an
interesting dude anyway
um but uh yeah I mean he's a [__]
slimy New York lawyer of course he's
[__] awful and did that right but
in in many ways uh you know you could
hit Trump on a lot of different things
this is just one of them I think the
RICO case in Georgia is way more solid
uh with respect to the phone call that
he had
thought way in my opinion it's like of
all the things to arrest him for I mean
he he paid he did a fake tax write-off
it's like I don't know inciting an
Insurrection yeah that's another good
one that you can hit him on so there's
that the dojs are still conducting an
investigation yeah as far as We Know
I think maybe the reason why the grand
jury is like uh holding out is possibly
because uh he might be indicted on like
some federal charges or something due to
the doj I'm just speculating here I'm
spitballing I have no idea
potentially be that the tension is too
as to uh maybe they're
is it the location secret where the
grand jury takes place
no I think it's in a courthouse which is
why because there's like threats against
them and it's too intense yeah they did
they did a bomb threat on the courthouse
but it's not that intense actually but I
think they're waiting for this to cool
off here's the thing yeah I think the
worst thing that could have ever
happened to Donald Trump wasn't
necessarily that he gets indicted for
you know paying hush money to a uh porn
star that he uh probably had uh sex with
for the first and last time in his
entire life I still maintain the
position that Donald Trump is an asexual
um just seeing yes uh but you know he
just for some reason for one reason or
the other he really likes Stormy Daniels
who he now calls horse face by the way
which is really kind of just like 130
Grand but then you also are calling her
horse face I have the video yeah
that's really kind of insane I mean we
talk about like
people that say less insane things
regularly and this is you know the
president these four calling someone a
horse face in front of someone he had
sex with yeah oh uh folks there's a
yacht is that the FBI yacht you can see
right there in the bottom of the screen
oh my God he's flashing oh my God what's
going on
it seems Joe Brandon has sent in uh
president uh dear leader XI jinping's
troops in a uh Chinese yacht down to
Mar-A-Lago to arrest him and extradite
him to Beijing
or sorry Ian breaking news do we have
the um ability to go back and analyze
that boat frame by frame yeah let's play
a live-action replay here do we have the
rewind capabilities
much like the police force we are also
defunded oh boy
be able to have the uh the capabilities
of rewinding here we're gonna find out
in our 20 gorillion dollar compound if
we can rewind the footage yes I'd like
to analyze frame by frame to see what's
going on there in Mar-A-Lago but yeah
here's the pre he's standing in front of
American flags in a damn suit calling a
woman a horse face and people are like
yeah yes that's my boy I mean what but
like also kind of an L like you you [__]
the horse face like what's that about
and you paid for it like
uh do you guys have the photo of him
next to Stormy Daniels in that one event
where he actually met her because yep
here I've got it that like here it is
you you can tell
like
oh yeah he's feeling himself like he's
so happy dude he's elated wait how long
ago was this because he looked 2006. he
looks horrible oh my God I love the font
the Disney font on myspace.com stormy
Daniel
damn like that's the face of a man who's
going yeah that's a woman oh he did it
he did it
yeah guilty straight up show that to the
[__] that's probably what they showed
at the Grand Jury they were like you
think this guy [__] her look at this
boom look at this photo and they were
like yeah oh yeah guilty yeah but let's
watch him calling her a horse she's not
actually a horse fish she's very
beautiful that's about to say she's very
pretty I don't know where she looks like
right I mean she has a beautiful face
yeah yeah or horrible radical left dad
your all-time favorite President me
continuation of the most disgusting
Witch Hunt in the history of our country
it's gone on forever with Russia Russia
the bronzer is getting so wild dude how
many layers of bronzer that man he lays
down on the pill he has to replace his
pillowcase every night bro he is gonna
be looking like Andrew take coming out
of jail whenever they pert walk him if
he goes to jail you're so right if he
goes to prison no more bronzer no more
hair supplements no more hair they're
just gonna I know I'm just fantasizing
come on all right all the fun I just
don't want you to get your hopes up for
Christ's sake no I mean I know it's not
gonna happen but I'm just having fun
with it that was like Andrew Tate three
months in prison per block yeah I just
want to know what happened to him like I
want to know he would look what he would
look like he would look like uh Darth
Vader at the end of the movie when it's
with his helmet off oh yeah
true it's like super pasty and just kind
of there was that one photo I think at
Mar-A-Lago when he looked a little
unkempt uh that that random like from
behind
shot well there was that one time
just completely [__] randomly he came
out with like a totally different style
do you remember that and his like hair
was done differently and everything and
he actually like kind of looked normal I
don't really remember this Trump looking
normal
yeah yep yeah here
no no no no no no no no no oh my God
yeah that was such a strange day he had
it and it only happened once like yeah
because everyone bullied him
Andy bro go back he experimented with a
with a gun screen that [__] his sex
appeal is through the roof man he's so
[__] hot
that outfit is doing a lot for me right
now that's like me when I was trying to
grow my hair out and everyone was like
dude it sucks don't do it and then I
didn't listen to everybody and I kept
growing it and now I look back at it I'm
like maybe it wasn't the best decision
you should do it King
absolute disgrace what's going on yes
they even spied in my campaign
and remember this with all of the work
that they did on Mueller no collusion
that's what the answer was was all no
Collision whether it's the Mar-A-Lago
raid or the unselect committee hoax
the perfect Georgia phone call it was
absolutely perfect
stormy horse face Daniel bro you stupid
dumbass [__] loser Distortion plot
bro he
speechless
no I don't know it's just bad form to
just be like I paid so much money to
have sex with a woman that I am now
calling horse face like that's a big
accurately pay to have sex with her what
we don't I don't know the no we did not
uh no one's alleged that he paid to have
sex with her he convinced her to have
sex with him uh allegedly by um
promising her a role on the Liberty
Apprentice yeah on celebrities that was
the game which uh did not work out for
her um that is not the payment came
later as a hush payment uh in 2016 so 10
years later oh scummy that's like
straight up Harvey Weinstein [__] right
there yeah a little bit
just sleep with me baby I'll get you up
they also um watched a lot of Shark Week
together reportedly oh yeah that that's
right that was a little detail that was
in there that really caught my eye
yeah shark week together he loved this
woman like he this is like the only time
Trump has ever loved anything but
himself he might be right that's why
he's so scorned that's why he's like a
horse face why did you do this to me we
had a beautiful time together yeah
watching Shark Week it was a perfect
time a beautiful time oh so here is well
of course
word is out that Trump might possibly
get arrested and as you uh might expect
The Usual Suspects such as Crowder and
Tim Poole
had something to say about it in fact
Tim Crowder's back Crowder's back yeah
oh damn uh yeah this week kind of fell
off a little bit what is he on Rumble I
haven't seen it I haven't even seen his
[__] he does like a hybrid Rumble bro he
Crowder hired one of these dumb [__] uh
uh Joe Rogan manosphere comedians Brian
Callahan Brian Callan works for yeah
Brian Callan is now part of the mug club
uh and so is Jim Brewer well it was just
announced the goat dude the goats of
Comedy that and so um Brian Callan is
the guy who is speculated to be the
unnamed friend in the uh
Chris D'Elia story
right is this wasn't chrisly outed on
their show
when he was like what you could yeah uh
in retrospect yeah that that famous yeah
people can save Snapchats yes yes that
moment yeah yeah that was it anyway
here's Crowder talking about what if
president Trump is arrested let's see
what happens
oh it's muted let's see what happens yo
it goes fire on mute this is what uh
many people are talking about and of
course like I said I what do you think
you think it's a PR stunt you think this
is happening what do you think the
results will be from this
[__] you did not just do that
this man just hit me with a bell and a
comment traffic yeah don't
you ever do that again he needs Buckle
fat removal
you think so it's like he's like his
body fat percentage is like not that
high but he has like a fatty face if he
got a little bit of if he got like
buccal fat removal I feel like he would
uh he would look a little bit more taut
you know what I mean you look a bit
confirm you could look a little bit
sexier I think leave a comment with your
ideas because it seems like despite the
fact that he has like a weak heart
a very very weak heart uh it seems like
he works out a lot a decent amount you
gotta appreciate it and art willing and
yeah
investing Donald Trump I don't know if
the Democrats are that bold
like that maybe some people am I crazy
cover them up [__] what is this nice
shirt look at that look at that top
person don't do this
but if you arrest your political
opponents people who are actively
seeking the presidency look do you guys
want to start a civil war because that's
how you start a civil war totally there
it is totally doing [__] no no Civil War
is going to happen you want to know why
I was briefly going to allude to this
the worst thing that could have possibly
happened to Donald Trump is
no crowds showing up for the potential
arrest there's two reasons for this I've
been thinking about this a lot number
one he kind of fell off let's be real
number two
January 6 and the subsequent
investigations that came after and the
people getting arrested basically
removed the sense of entitlement that
all of these like small business owners
in [__] Florida and Arkansas
uh uh realize like oh no we're not above
the law if we like uh do you know our
own Brown Shirts movement
oh sorry um and and last but not least
and this is perhaps the most important
factor I said two but I'm gonna give you
three important bonus here
um
a lot of right-wing mobilization is
Astro turfed
but what I mean by that is like there
are a lot of 501c4s there's a lot of
groups like Turning Point USA that
basically bus people
to these sorts of events yeah they it's
always projection when they say George
Soros is like you know paying protests
like they literally will look for people
to fill rooms like they did at the uh at
CPAC right they'll hire people to fill
rooms they'll hire people to go to
events and stuff and there's like
professional protesters obviously that
they send everywhere
um and I don't think the Republican
party is backing I don't think the
Republican party is backing Trump like
that any longer which is part of the
reason why that infrastructure is no
longer available to him which is why you
don't really see a lot of people now
it could either be because a they don't
want Donald Trump to be president which
they've made very clear
or B they are afraid of January 6
happening again which will hurt Trump's
chances overall even if he does become
president or whatever see yeah gigachad
Stephen Buckle fat removed actually
don't do that you look more like me when
you do that and I don't like that oh my
God wait I like this look what
that looks so much like you
I don't like that whoa hello
that's that's uh gay and also ungodly
and you'd [__] him like that it scares
you
I just think he would look too much like
me and I don't like that are they people
already make those comparisons son you
always you always take off pretty quick
after the show
have you ever seen them enough I've
never seen Crowder Hassan together
Heaven gay
although his head is normal proportion
ah thank God yeah right that gives it
away no my head is much larger than his
head that's what you meant right Ethan
well proportion I'm talking proportions
yeah he's Crowder and Tim they're giant
cowards they're not gonna do [__]
they're like not me we're gonna do a
civil war not me though I have too much
to live for you know who's the biggest
coward the biggest fake friend
Marjorie Taylor green who came out and
was like don't protest don't do it no
matter what happens don't protest this
it's obviously unjustifiable but don't
protest which is like what Kevin
McCarthy's been saying which is what
everyone in the Republican party has
been saying but I was shocked to see
that for Marjorie Taylor green who made
a name for herself by being the radical
you know the real what is he doing
fear and anger this most powerful
combination the groups are driving the I
wonder if somebody got to her like
because like the cop Brothers don't want
civil right you know who you know who
[__] god there Kevin McCarthy that's
what he's laying it down no he's just
laying it down I think oh I suspect I
suspect that I suspect that Marjorie
tiller green and Kevin McCarthy are
having sex yes
that is my suspicion that is the
bombshell it must be some good dick to
get her if he's talking like that strong
strong woman like that needs a a beta
man to dominate like Kevin McCarthy no I
saw the way that Kevin McCartney put
Matt gates in order when he was being a
little [__] I think he's he's got no
there is no I I think I think they're
all [__] they're all [__] awful
monsters but they're all cowardly little
[__] when push comes to shove they're
all like Democrats like that's that is
literally what a democratic that's like
Chuck Schumer would write that you know
what I mean like I know that the
Republicans are threatening the future
of America let's go to the Trump sorry
but let's let's vote extra hard next
week you know that's like what they say
all right let's watch this I want to get
a I want to get a taste for what these
guys are saying indictment this is what
uh many people are talking about oh can
I tell you something funny after I The
Little Leprechaun sidekick got fired
when he moved to rumble
yeah Dave's out
no we don't know if he got fired
that guy has no prospects in life bro
how dare you Ethan he is he is the
number one divorce maybe [__] river
dancing on on Saint Patty's Day next
year whoa he's the number one divorce
dad comic in the United States of
America really no I'm
that's a stiff competition I'm just
saying that he might be
no oh I by the way the CEO of tick
tock's being grilled right now if we
have any interesting Clips I want to
watch that he's being grilled by cars
wait let's see what this is all I got
from Stephen what do you think you think
that's PR stunt you think this is
happening what do you think the results
will be from this
look arresting Donald Trump I don't know
if the Democrats are that bold and I
don't know if they want this frankly
somebody thinks that maybe some people
have top are saying don't do this
because it will backfire uh but if you
arrest your political opponents people
who are actively seeking the presidency
look do you guys want to start a civil
war because that's how you start a civil
war yeah no no I want it but I'm saying
no if you look throughout history
jailing political opponents is kind of
one of the key items that pop [__] off
shut up idiot stupid ass dumbass they're
just gonna take his fingerprint shut the
[__] up that's that's who he's talking
about no he's I love I love the Nelson
Mandela comparisons like they're like
this is our Nelson Mandela you know what
I mean yeah
Nelson Mandela was in jail for yeah 47
years
so yeah Temple uh just says War Temple
of course the bravest American Patriot
he's ready to go wait wait hold on he's
a liberal what do you mean
he's just saying that descriptively he's
saying like wow this is War I think can
we get more details War absolutely
okay what kind of Weaponry do you think
would be valid for civilians to use oh
that's an individual citizen in this
country has a right to own a nuclear
warhead
interesting okay well yeah let's avoid
that
that rocks yeah he's just like you know
what you know what the problem is though
it's definitely not me yeah no no of
course not uh whoa it seems by the way
you're you're
um
your Twitter it's been awesome lately
stop stop I don't like this I don't like
this
oh my God I hate this what did you do
with your hair you look good
okay first of all that's objectively
false how dare you
[__] stupid bro don't be so hard on
yourself I think you look good you look
great it's all good man be confident if
Stephen Crowder gets Buckle fat removal
is over for me
well you'll have to get waffle fat and
then you'll have to transform even
deeper no I already have uh good facial
features I'm I'm good well no you have a
little Buckle to remove everyone we can
we'll do a little work on you don't
worry we'll figure it out Tito said
let's take a minute for standing ovation
to Ethan oh oh for giving a performance
of a lifetime
breaking news oh let's get back to that
there it is like being the void well
hold on yeah but that's just this is
important for being the voice of us all
yesterday and handling a Content a
contentious conversation with Grace
Candor humility here's the 42 years of
wisdom okay we glazed you up for like
while you were hooping up a storm or
glazed you for like 15 minutes listen
they donated they donated you still need
to read the comments I'm just reading a
donation that's my that's my obligation
well unfortunately I'm hearing reports
from Ian in the control room that it is
not possible to do that replay again
very easily it took him that last 15
minutes too can I see it again no wait
what I can't
it's probably like the state flag of
Delaware or some [__] that's where
usually people uh buy their boats can
you do it again Ian
okay one more time here watch closely
everybody it's not the state flag of
Delaware but it's a state flag I thought
it might have been a Confederate flag
but I didn't get enough look go ahead
Ian okay here it is here we go back on
the grounds of marlago taking a quick
look at this boat fit
sailed on by cruised on by we're gonna
be taking a uh we're waiting for of
course 20 seconds now to enter the frame
here any second all right here it is oh
here we go okay the boat is entering
it's a nice looking kind of luxury yacht
I like what I'm seeing does not look
like federal agents would be on board of
that unless it was some kind of
clandenstein clandestine uh operation
oh you think this is like a rogue cell
so what with the red flag is what's
intriguing me oh no is it what is it
Australian no is it yeah right red it's
it's the Aussie flag isn't it but it's
probably it was like uh I don't think so
it's an Aussie flag no no it's probably
like uh like a a a state inside of uh
Australia or something maybe or yeah the
Australian flag is a similar pattern but
it's a blue field
they had this one like this [__] that's
the flag of Bermuda Bermuda uh Bermuda
well what are they doing with the [__]
what do you mean that's where you bought
that's why I thought immediately
Delaware like when you buy a boat
come on you're rich dude I'm not bubble
dude rich guy okay first of all you're
definitely boat ready
that boat probably costs like 20 mil
okay I doubt it but um what bro those
Yachts are they're pretty they're pretty
[__] yeah I agree with that 20 mil
excuse me Hassan I've watched every
episode of below deck so do not question
me I don't I actually don't know
anything about boat prices but I do know
that people buy boats like uh in in you
know like island nations like that or
American island nations like Delaware
like tax shelters basically you know
what I'd like to do Duke can you pull
some highlights of the ongoing Tick Tock
um uh so I do have a few in the dock
already if you scroll up there's a
section called Tick Tock this is our
home tick tock is our home there's a
couple of links here with just some
stuff I've been seeing getting traction
on as you guys know the CEO of tick tock
at Tick Tock is being heavily considered
to be either banned or forced to sell to
an American company is my home and uh I
am obviously hugely hugely opposed to
that Hassan the main Chief reads I could
go on and on about all these legitimate
reasons the only real reason of course
is that it would benefit Ryan Kavanaugh
who owns triller and we cannot allow
that to happen wait why well because why
would that benefit him when last time
Tick Tock was almost banned where they'd
stop the new downloads of the app people
doctor trailer
oh no we can't let that happen that's
what I'm saying this is outrageous I I
don't want Tick Tock to be sold because
I love Xi Jinping
right and I I think he should have
access to uh all the information he
wants to see nobody well anyway
anyway so he's in front of Congress and
he's getting grilled by both Republicans
and Democrats that's not looking good uh
Ryan Kavanaugh is probably jerking off
at home right now but the only time that
like American Congress will ever get
together and do anything bipartisan is
like if we can uh be fueled by
xenophobia yeah like our our desires to
make sure that what was it possible
is going on that's definitely a trash
boat
hmm is that what we're is that what
we're calling a barge is it is it
possible federal agents could be aboard
the bar I mean look I don't know it
doesn't seem like it but I also do know
that our studio capabilities no longer
have the uh the ability to rewind the
footage that is a we're working on
obtaining that technology yeah rewind
time okay so if we take so this is a bar
yeah these barges are looking a little
different I don't know we'll do a small
bar Dan I mean a small barge small
Garbage barge okay so it barges of all
shapes and sizes garbage now do federal
agents use barges so we General agents
yeah use barges right
there so here we have uh the they do
apparently uh they appear to be
um some sort of boat uh could be a barge
hard to tell from here we'll do some
more digging okay so in the meantime
let's let's go to um Tick Tock yeah here
it is Mr Chew does tick tock access the
home Wi-Fi network
what if the user turns on the Wi-Fi I'm
sorry I may not understand that Tick
Tock app on my phone and my phone is on
my home Wi-Fi network does tick tock
access that Network
it will have to to access the network to
get connections to the internet if
that's the question is it possible then
that it could access other devices on
that home Wi-Fi network
Congressman that we do not do anything
that is beyond any industry Norms
um I believe the answer to your question
is no it could be technical let me get
back to you okay I'd appreciate if you
could answer that
I find it [__] interesting that when
these Boomers they glow they got their
shot in the sun to ask this important
guy an important question there's no
intern there's no young person in or is
nobody reviewing that to be like dude
this is so dumb do not ask him this does
it Access Wi-Fi I think well I think the
people that they have in their in their
staff are also old that's the problem
they don't have any interns
actually low-key that's not like the
dumbest question I I was ready to make
fun of this guy but it's not the dumbest
question because
um
like uh we don't know what level of like
uh data uh apps collect
more like information like what other
devices are connecting to your to your
Wi-Fi obviously you can't like spy on
your cameras or anything he he what he's
getting at is does your router do you
are you getting information from your
router about other devices in the
household well your iPhone is so that's
why I'm saying like depending on how
much data can your uh can any given app
collect from your iPhone they could
technically maybe have access to it but
I believe the way he worded it Mr does
tick tock access the home Wi-Fi network
I mean come on only if the user turns on
the Wi-Fi I I'm sorry I mean I mean it
does an insanely dumb way to work
amazing yeah I think you might be right
about what the intent of the question
was but yeah I think it's not like that
I don't think it's that crazy of a
question actually surprisingly because
oftentimes it'll be like it will
literally have you will have like a
demon okay who is somehow still alive
even though they're like 800 years old
asking Mark Zuckerberg like why won't my
grandchildren call me back on Facebook
like that's questions like that that are
like really [__] up okay well here's
one that them deadly tick tock challenge
is also a real thing for the record okay
I can't believe I'm like defending the
Congress right now no you're on the
right side of History we need to ban
Tick-Tock
um
challenges are a real thing how many
people is Ryan Kavanagh going to hurt
if he becomes a successful businessman
again you guys are not considering both
sides is short-sighted okay sometimes in
life you choose between two evils and
you want to choose the Lesser evil okay
Ryan Kavanaugh could do Untold damages
to this world if you were to obtain
billions of dollars the last time you
had billions of dollars the [__] La
uh police had to intervene because he
was flying his helicopter into
neighborhoods and making all kinds of
crazy noise and [__] who Brian Kavanaugh
wait really when he was on top of the
world the police had to be like yo stop
Flying your [__] helicopter in our
neighbor in a residential neighborhood
and Landing there idiot right now
there's just this Great Divide you know
there's a fight I think uh in Minecraft
I don't have that I know there's a
helicopter really there was some
helicopter
but uh don't you know the checks
technically they're correct on this as
well there's another there is actually a
uh there's actually a court case from
not mistaken about Tick Tock child this
is what actually sparked uh
uh some criticism against Tick Tock okay
let me watch this let me watch this
talking about children dying do you know
any children who died because of this do
you have any idea can you tell me uh
Congressman again it's heartbreaking can
you tell me how many children in America
have died because of challenges like
this the majority of people who use
Health platform use it for positive
experiences that's not what I asked you
never ask you tell me the number of
children of U.S children who have died
because of these challenges Congressman
again
the majority of majority of people who
come on our platform I'm not talking
about the majority of children I want to
know a number I want to know how many
children have died on platform if we
find them we will remove them we take
this obviously they said it the Chinese
man said he wants to remove our children
thank you for being here welcome again I
I actually I do need to disagree with
you on this I don't I don't think that
this is us
it's not really a serious uh issue in my
opinion
hold on it's not it's hold on go on
people do dumb [__] on every [__] app
how are you going to hold Tick Tock
accountable because there's a little
that was a couple of dumb shits that was
the point I was gonna make as well which
is that like stupid the argument this is
why I started the conversation 200
million people use tick tock of course
there's gonna be two dumb shits that you
describe okay okay that is literally
what I was gonna say and then that's why
I started the conversation
these guys are motivated to do anything
it's through xenophobia because it's
like the China app right but like what
they are criticizing Tick Tock for oh my
God they could literally criticize every
single application every single social
media platform has these exact same
issues and and uh I don't even know what
the best way to regulate that sort of
thing is if I'm if I'm being real
um so they're they're kind of like
bullying singling out Tick Tock for the
the the very same problems that every
single application has like as far as
spying as far as like all of your data
that can be captured on your phone on
your social media platform every every
single social media platform could
absolutely be hit with that exact same
thing but of course they have back doors
of the NSA they have back doors of the
FBI and CIA so it doesn't matter right
yes it's US spying on everyone else
although it doesn't matter these are
American corporations when China does it
it's bad
um I think it's bad across the board for
the record if you want to understand
what my perspective is but the reason
why they're singling out Tick Tock for
it is because China is doing it same
thing goes for the content moderation on
this platform
every single U.S based social media
application has the exact same issues
with content moderation with content
regulation uh if not worse than Tick
Tock in some respects but tick tock's
getting called out for it because it's a
Chinese application
um last but not least
as far as content regulation goes tick
tock's algorithm is out of control right
it's the worst one out of all of the
platforms because it's the it's the most
unhinged one basically I think Tom yeah
it's the most unhinged it's the most
unhinged because it's the most like on
steroids as far as like uh trying to
keep you purposely on uh
yeah which is why what's the nature of
the content I think yeah which is you're
watching you're getting they're getting
new data points so much faster than
other ones that they're able to
guide you wherever the [__] you know
yeah it well it's nature of the Beast I
think I agree with you and by the way
Google is also utilizing shorts with and
very successfully mind you
um but
um as far as tick tock goes as far as
the content uh that pops off on Tick
Tock uh it is the same problem with like
early YouTube you know not early YouTube
but like pre-2016 era YouTube of like
white supremacist content because more
radicalizing content is keeping users on
the platform for longer so Tick Tock or
the algorithms are trained to move
towards whatever kind of content is like
keeping users on the platform
one thing I will say is this
doyun which is the Chinese version of
tick tock say it again
did a little of that inflection on there
yeah is owned by the same company the
same Chinese company that owns tick tock
is
extremely controlled
like the information dissemination on
that is super controlled especially for
younger populations uh what you see is
super Limited you know what I mean so
just think about that I don't think
sorry think about what you're watching
think about what your kids are watching
on tick tock uh that kind of uh
commentary that kind of content would be
completely unacceptable in China
um so I think it doesn't even [__]
allow our social media networks they
don't even allow they don't even allow
Tick Tock yeah that's what I mean like
talk to the Chinese company and there's
a Chinese version
I agree it's stupid as [__] for trying
to call us hypocrite when they don't
even allow but but anyway YouTube
is my home here's the CEO defending Tick
Tock Hassan ownership is the issue here
with a lot of respect American Social
companies don't have a good record with
data privacy and user security I mean
look at Facebook and Cambridge analytica
yeah just one example so get them really
y'all gonna like like start grumbling
like how dare oh you talk [__] about
yeah
Mark Zuckerberg is a demon bro as far as
we know Facebook is played a role like a
a calculable role in the genocide of uh
Muslims rohingya Muslims right in
Myanmar Facebook played a role in that
Mark Zuckerberg came out and said oh
sorry I guess do enough moderation
that's what I'm saying you had a couple
tripods and now we were at a band ticket
has yet to play a role actively in
genocide uh other than what genocide
brother how do we know the only good Jam
side how do we even know that the kids
that ate those Tide Pods was not part of
a false flag operation yeah those aren't
real kids that's right you're right
just one example so
so I can't believe you think that you
know it is not about the ownership it is
a lot about making sure we have project
Texas making sure that we're protecting
a firewalling U.S user data from unwanta
foreign access giving third parties to
come in to have a look at this and
making sure that everybody is
comfortable we're giving transparency
and third party monitoring and that's
what we're doing for yeah but China
definitely can access our info like I
mean China has um there was
investigative reporting done on this
matter where uh I think I believe the
Chinese government had access or
requested access and got access to uh a
journalist's right I remember journals
like Tick Tock information not entirely
certain on who the journalist was or
what the uh motivation there was [__]
up it was a journalist was doing
reporting on Tick Tock saying that the
Chinese could access information and in
response there was some Tick Tock
employees in China who had the you know
Master access they were like wait we can
they did [__] Recon on that journal
analysts they're accessing her personal
information
in I guess
um let's say you know
yeah and retaliation and uh so yeah I do
they can yeah yeah I I think so now
they're saying that uh in an effort to
you know get away from this possible
like National ban or whatever Tick Tock
will which by the way is
unconstitutional for the record
this is uh this would never be allowed
if it wasn't a Chinese company
um
so let's get that let's get that right
does China have constitutional rights no
I'm saying an American like in the
United States of America I'm a firm
believer that like the United States of
America and the government should be
able to block Commerce if a company is
behaving in a way that is inconsistent
with the principles right and by that I
mean let's say an American company is
not paying taxes let's say that they
want to move to Ireland to utilize it as
a tax Haven okay you can no longer have
access to the American Consumer base
you're done come back pay us [__]
taxes or you're done you're not able to
access our Market
that's what I think that's what I
believe that you should be doing but the
only time they'll ever do it is for like
[__] Tick Tock is owned by a Chinese
uh owned by the Chinese government
this one scary thing I've heard about uh
the privacy and data thing that I think
is is a total [__] excuse the one
thing that does scare me
because we've seen this used to great
effect already on Facebook is that they
could tweak the algorithm to manipulate
people into going down certain rabbit
holes yeah influencing people 100 on
YouTube and we see it on Facebook so it
would be probably not even it would be
easy for them to send people down
conspiracy rabbit holes and send people
down white nationalists uh rabbit holes
even to be like pro-china conspiracy
wish dude like I mean that's not
happening though and that I wish they
would go down that rabbit hole and then
pump my pump my [__] up gee I'm here for
you I'm here for you I mean I am your
strongest Soldier sir unfortunately what
they would probably do is just Stoke uh
racial tensions to so Discord that you
know they do just something just totally
awful to make our society crumble and uh
I think which is what we see you know on
Facebook I think even without like uh
openly uh trying to do anything uh
mischievous like that
they still are doing that by just
letting the algorithm run uh in the way
that it's running currently without even
like deliberately directing it to a
political ideology
it's still doing right well we learned
when the algorithm just does its job on
YouTube
it sends you down [__] up rabbit holes
by Nature
yeah because it keeps you watching so
um thank you Derek runs for the Bermuda
boat fund donation it's a unique it's a
unique predicament because like I think
that uh tiktok is rotting the minds of
Americans uh but that brain Rod already
like nothing to do with the Congress
I'm sorry I don't think that's I think
that that
is not government's role to be like we
think this is bad for the Youth I mean
how many times have we heard that in our
[__] lifetime because you're American
what are we going to Bear music if you
go back to the 60s yeah no I I
understand it sets a very Un-American
precedent but it's uh it's silly it
doesn't it's not consistent it's per
it's you know it's not it's subjective
it's not uh I don't have an issue with
like uh you know federal government
interfering in the uh in in Commerce I
think that the reason why they're doing
this however and the reason why they
have like even the reason why they can
even start this process is uh because
it's it's a Chinese company and they
want to sell it to an American uh they
want to sell it to an American
corporation they want to sell to an
American citizen uh that's what they
want to do and obviously the Chinese
government doesn't want to do that why
the [__] would they you know what I mean
that's like this is a massive massively
successful corporation that like you
correctly pointed out could genuinely
manipulate the minds of 200 million
people or even more globally right
so I mean it's just the the foot the
shoes on the other foot because
America's has always owned all the most
powerful social media companies that are
used worldwide right and so if anybody
knows how that can be abused it's the US
government
and uh no they they want to they want it
they want it all yeah they want it for
themselves they're jealous they are
jealous and they should be yeah Tick
Tock is is massively successful hey
maybe our Innovation isn't [__] up to
stuff you know maybe the Chinese did it
better and maybe we need just to step
our [__] up invest in education invest
in [__] Technologies you know what I
mean invest in to people or or you know
maybe a little bit of information
control isn't the the worst thing
overall except the government is never
going to use that for a good reason
they're going to use it for whatever
ideological reasoning they have which
would immediately eviscerate content
creators like myself I think it's such a
bad precedent though to start Banning
Chinese products like you're gonna ban
Tick Tock because it's owned by Chinese
people so we can't do business with
Chinese like are we going to start like
where do we start and stop I know but
it's like where do we stop and start
using Chinese content then and then uh
products and then in China they're gonna
be like okay you ban talk then you know
we'll do this and it's like uh it'll be
fair they'd if it's a tip for Tad they
did kind of started I mean like we were
saying like you can't get on YouTube you
can't get on American social media
anywhere in China right I mean I know
you can get around it and that will
probably be the case for tick tock too
right like I don't think Americans are
gonna I mean just create like VPN
culture in America like it is in other
countries I don't know right but um to
China start it by Banning social medias
yeah but that was never even in question
yeah it was like that was not even a
thing like China was always like nope no
shot you're not you are not able there
are any like big tech companies or
anybody that uh does work in China that
does you know they do but they make
their own versions like Microsoft you
know is big in China yeah and window but
like there's like a Chinese windows that
right so we just want to do that
uh well originally that's what it
sounded like they were doing what I
haven't seen has any I haven't seen in
any of the Clips in this hearing
addressing this but like they worked out
a whole deal where they were going to
have Oracle in America
collection why is that not good Oracle
did you data collection that was going
to be like I don't know inaccessible to
China
but I don't even believe that I think
China would still be able to uh that's
probably I mean maybe that's it maybe
they just figured that wouldn't be good
enough but Doug worked out a great deal
what happened
I I think this is a truly unique and
very interesting
case because like not to be Centrist on
this and I I'm oh I'm not but I do I do
see valid uh arguments on both sides of
the conversation yeah um it's one of
those situations where like I'm not
super firmly when you consider the Ryan
Kavanaugh Factor it obviously tells you
yeah we need to have Tick Tock out
that's where I'm at too unless what if
Ryan Kavanaugh bought Tick Tock too
Brian Cava Brian Kavanaugh can barely
pay his rent bro
this is his last this is his Hail Mary
all right let's see what she has to say
she says uh
let's see
Tick Tock collects nearly every data
point imaginable
from people's location to what they type
and copy who they talk to biometric data
and more biometric even if they've never
been on Tick Tock their trackers are
embedded in sites across the web
Tick Tock surveils us all
and the Chinese Communist party is able
to use this
as a whole
we do not trust Tick Tock will ever
Embrace American values values for
Freedom human rights and Innovation
wrong stop pause it tick tock okay this
is like uh this is like a the dangest
attitude okay you're so wrong on this
the reason why Tick Tock is so
successful is it is it is because it has
embraced American values down to the
[__] core baby
unfiltered pure content juice
that's why they don't allow it in China
so if you're wrong about that it's
actually the mirror that is facing back
at you that you [__] despise let's be
[__] real oh man China is Never Gonna
Embrace American values no that's they
did they did do that that's what you're
right you're dead absolutely did that
right
we do not trust Tick Tock will ever
Embrace American values values for
freedom freedom human rights and
Innovation yes all of our tech companies
famously stand for human rights yeah no
they're just again it's more it's more a
situation where it's like we're kind of
pissed off that you're doing what we do
to everybody else this this next couple
of these next couple of Decades of
multi-polarity potentially fingers
crossed inshallah we'll be wait we'll be
we'll be riddled with China doing
America [__] maybe in the in a less uh
violent way okay and then America
getting upset that China's doing America
[__] while they just routinely agitate
yeah it's a Spider-Man meme
pointing the finger at one another
because like they're this is it this
this entire Congressional hearing is
like how dare you do America [__] the
only we get to do that what the [__]
Tick Tock is repeatedly chosen the path
for more control more surveillance and
more manipulation
your platform should be banned shut up
you're such an idiot that's not the
reason why everybody does that I mean
that's fair do it to Zuckerberg and get
on [__] they will never they I mean I'm
in I'm in favor of more content
moderation I just uh
I don't even care if the government like
threatens them for more content
moderation and doesn't actually like act
out on it
um Tick Tock certainly needs it every
social media platform certainly needs it
but obviously uh not at the behest of
the uh capitalist freakish uh
imperialist American uh federal
government and like the direction that
they choose these old [__] Boomers
don't know anything right
um but uh that's why I say I'm in the
middle on this like I've seen better
days man that guy in the back yeah this
guy had a long devastated
oh he must be an attorney right for him
no he's that's like Charlie demelio's
biggest fan he's like so worried he is
having a hard time like no please don't
let this doesn't Charlie get off the
platform here's a interesting uh
and what we've already established about
the ability of the Chinese Communist
party to access personal user data would
you agree that no U.S government
electronic devices should have access to
Tick-Tock platform as your lackluster
security currently stands I disagree
with that characterization like I said
any individual should be utilizing that
on any government platform
I think the government devices shouldn't
have no social media apps to be honest
right and Target it to us Mr Chu join
this year I mean he's not wrong
take it out you know if it's important
let's just why why are government
devices have any social media on it yeah
I love that like I mean he's not yeah
dude they literally [__]
they use like a different version of
Fitbit uh uh the military secret
military bases were Unearthed because
people were using fitbits to run while
they were running around the base in the
mornings like uh uh the the
at the weakest point in every uh
security the the weakest point is always
human social engineering is like a big
chunk of what hacking actually is
nowadays because human beings are super
flawed it's the it's the easiest way to
breach any kind of uh possibly secure
platform
that's why I don't well these guys have
social media on their phones
yeah I mean
we got to keep the location of this
bunker secure
yeah
they've um
they once even found uh uh the the
nuclear launch codes because
people are using the flashcards webcam
website
the flat oh wow to memorize nuclear
launch codes
so it was like he's in flash cards yeah
to memorize nuclear launches uh nuclear
launch base or something in the
Netherlands if I'm not mistake they
don't write that down like on a little
piece of paper or something
the launch code well they do but then
they have to I guess memorize it so in
order to memorize it they were putting
it on the flashcard web uh website that
seems insane that's like really crazy
like that's just not like well you know
that's just not right
uh that's not the right use for that
website all right well moving on I think
we you know we touched on that a little
bit we've got one more thing get my eyes
peeled for any year yeah because I think
it's still going on it's all wrapping up
we've talked a bit about uh big old dump
Trump trump dump truck Trump first
meatball Ron why is nobody call them
dump truck Trump dump truck Trump it's
hard to say
I call them that thumbs up
trunk say that ten times I talk about
his dumpy all the time
yeah here it is uh here they are they're
heating up actually exchanges are
getting heated up but yeah oh meatball
meatball Ron is done by the way you
think he's cooked no no I'm saying the
nickname meatball run yeah that's such a
big L for Trump it's not like hit that
line more
um
I think it's good for two reasons one
it's funny uh two he looks like a
meatball and three uh anti-italian
sentiment is always encouraged right
here he is addressing uh the accusation
that he is in fact a meatball
yes ma'am hi uh Megan from the Florida
standard uh we wanted to know what your
thoughts are on the rumored Trump
indictment and if you have any role in
it um if charges are brought on him
would you have any Rule and extradition
to New York
so I've seen rumor swirl is this the
wrong um time stamp uh it's not the
wrong time stamp is if you were looking
for the meatball clip that's the wrong
clip altogether it's 5A 5A is the
meatball clip should I watch this one uh
yeah this one's juicy too I have to pee
real quick oh my God it's all falling
apart now I'm sorry
uh yeah okay not the indictment about
the here he is talking about the
indictment yes uh yet and so I don't
know what's going to happen but I do
know this the the Manhattan district
attorney is a Soros funded prosecutor
and so okay he like other Soros funded
prosecutors sounds like wait he's
defending Trump here right like saying
this this D.A is corrupt George Soros uh
owns his life and uh why how is he
defending Trump
because he's criticizing the D.A and
he's saying oh but you'll see it takes a
turn in a second he's defending Trump at
this moment yeah and in the next break
can that prosecutor be Soros funded so I
I you know what I mean they work for the
government they always talk about
Soros right and
it's just become like background noise
like it just seems like it's just
something they always throw up but on
this one because he said it I actually
looked it up last night what does this
mean
George Soros paid donated a bunch of
money to a Super PAC that sponsored him
in his election for district attorney so
weird I mean it's just so like anti it's
just really giving me anti-semitic
conspiracy theory
yeah I mean that's the root of all of
the George Soros thing because none of
them have any problem with billionaires
donating to Super Pacs and funding
campaign they all do it yeah exactly
they all do it it's just these Sorrows
funded yeah weaponize their office to
impose a political agenda on Society at
the expense of the rule of law and
Public Safety he has downgraded over 50
percent of the felonies to misdemeanors
he says he doesn't want to even have
jail time for the vast vast majority of
crimes and what we've seen in Manhattan
is we've seen the sky the crime rate go
up and we've seen citizens become less
they're so stupid shut the [__] up
talking about this season with and look
it's the same [__] all the time like it
is literally the same principle behind
like
um you know uh is the same principle
behind like trying to undo the mistakes
of like the the the War on Drugs you
know what I mean it's just like
low-level offenses minor offenses uh uh
are are should not be treated with like
the same level of scrutiny is what
they're saying it's not like if you do a
violent felony if you like murder
someone they need to rot that you don't
know
executed bro also wasn't there just like
total Anarchy in uh Miami the lot like
they they issued like a curfew because
there was so much like violence going on
in Miami just the oh for spring break I
guess it was a spring break related yeah
that makes sense
Lawless just a little ironic that you
know Lawless DeSantis it was like
New York's uh like
like Lindsey Graham was talking about
this when he was like yeah New York is
Lawless and and riddled with crime and
it's like when you look at the [__]
when you look at New York's like murder
rate versus uh versus uh South
Carolina's uh murder rate
uh it literally is is like triple it's
triple like it's almost triple it's like
10 to I think 4.7 damn the 10.3 to 4.7
so like shut the [__] up Lindsey Graham
fix your own goddamn backyard I hate
when like I absolutely despise and yes
either your question answer to your
question is yes
New York primary has increased uh over
the past year but if you look at overall
crime it is of course on a downward
Trend regardless
um let's let's listen to the meatball
sizzle
price money to a porn star to to secure
so back it up a little bit because so
now he talked over the turn here yeah
yeah you that part is important he's
doing he's doing it all he's taking both
he's sitting on the fence here yeah for
the vast vast majority of crimes and
what we've seen in Manhattan pause it
one more time I'm sorry I'm sorry we
have to we have to talk about this it it
[__] makes me so angry dog Florida's
crime rate New York is five percent
lower at
358.6 violent crimes per 100 000
residents versus Florida's
378.4 rate this is from 2019 2019
violent crime numbers show murder
robbery assault and rape rates in
Florida and New York are similar but New
York is about five percent lower
a significant five percent
five percent is everything five percent
is everything it's just like he takes
that five he takes that five percent
there it is yeah so citizens become less
safe and so you're talking about this
situation with and look I don't know
what goes into paying hush money to a
porn star to to stop the silence over
some type of alleged Affair I just I
can't speak to that
because he doesn't know anything about
that he's literally like though he's
like oh this D.A is full of [__] he
charges but he says the institution is
corrupt of course so now I don't know
anything about [__] a prostitute and
paying her off no that's the question
though like if you're gonna [__] say
that like he he had sex with a porn star
and then paid hush money then you agree
with the d8 yeah you [__] coward
Rhonda silent you should have stayed
silent on this oh got him fake friends I
hate him you know one Governor two faces
you know what I'm saying like it's just
[__] it's [__] you know it's
weird they say that the weather in
Florida is good all year round but uh
somehow DeSantis is still a fair weather
friend yeah Autumn freaking got him give
it to him Ethan
thank you
give it to him
brilliant the weather doesn't looking so
fair out there in Florida
is that if you have a prosecutor also
the weather is
hurricanes yeah
crimes happening every single day all
right shut up meatball by the way he
literally repeated Trump's line like bar
for bar but New York is riddled with
violent crime the D.A should focus on
that instead of like uh coming after my
daddy
um and Trump owns him Trump owns him so
hard he owned him immediately right here
hit him with the yeah so Trump is back
at the santis uh he goes he says
here we go Ron will probably find out
about this sometime in the future when
he's unfairly and illegally attacked by
women or possibly a man oh got him with
false accusations he said LOL you're gay
Gay Ron Gay Ron you're gay
gay gay gay gay gay
that's fire that's such an effective
tactic it's so good hit me with the the
gay course choir
thank you I love that that's my favorite
sound but
okay
it's so powerful to me it it
reverberates to my soul yeah he hit him
back he hit him back with the with the
allegations like you know you will have
to address allegations eventually Ron
here check this out Ronald we sometimes
ask chat GPT to Crunch uh high-level
statistics for us so this is what it
spit out
historically both New York City and
Florida have experienced folliculate
fluctuations in crime rates over the
years in recent years New York has seen
a decrease in crime rates according to
data from New York City Police
Department in contrast Florida has also
experienced fluctuations in crime rates
and the rates vary by region according
to data from the Florida Department of
Law Enforcement overall crime in the
state decreased by 11.3 percent in 2020
compared to the European GPS covid
that's why it doesn't seem very serious
either way then it went back to
pre-covered levels that's why it
increased okay also sorry don't come out
don't come at me with these liberal
machines that can't say the n-word okay
if you can't say the n-word I don't want
to hear about your takes on crime that's
fair yeah you don't have to we just need
to know you can't no you you have to no
you have let me let me preface by saying
this n-word okay let me move on to your
question yeah that's that's what that's
what chachibd's supposed to be saying uh
Donald Trump continues the onslaught to
meatball ROM tossing him in a pan of
marinara
run run to sanctimonious we'll probably
find out about false accusations and
fake stories sometimes in the future as
he gets older wiser and better known
when he's unfairly and illegally
attacked by a woman even classmates that
are quote underage or possibly a man uh
oh I'm sure he will want to fight these
Misfits just like I do pedo Gamers and
Ron it might be a little boy who we
don't know don't kiss the guys and the
beautiful women and them
the Ron DeSantis party with underage
girls while drinking while being a
teacher this shit's wild as [__] bro I
didn't know about all this Ron DeSantis
used to be a tea high school teacher and
he's partying with his students and
drinking with them like brother what the
[__] is that yeah that's not good I'm at
this high school girl that I was hot as
[__] tonight like why well Trump isn't
it
can't tell keemstar isn't really or
Trump isn't really the one to deliver
that criticism but I do feel like this
is a powerful no it doesn't matter it's
amazing how little what do you mean it
doesn't matter you just say whatever the
[__] he wants there's so many pictures
of him with Jeffrey Epstein there's a
lot of who cares yeah we've learned
anything over the past couple of years
it's just Vibes base okay Trump is the
Great White Hope he's defending the uh
you know he's defending the white race
he can say whatever the [__] he wants
the Italian meatball Ron meatball Ron he
puts parmesan on everything folks yeah
he drowns at in Parma it's disgusting
like
that's that's why it was so funny when
they were like when when people that are
you know hyping up uh Rhonda Santas were
like sir if I were you I wouldn't be
talking about who's potentially a
pedophile it's like dude you voted for
him twice and have been defending him
Non-Stop and are going to defend him
when he inevitably wins the [__]
primaries why are you saying you're
voting for a pedophile and defending a
pedophile if you're implying that he's a
pedophile we're all in good company who
are we to throw stones we've all [__]
kids let's be real
um Ron says he doesn't know what
sanctimonious means okay King he
responds to the nicknames let's see what
he thinks about it and we'll wrap it up
after this Hassan I know you got to go
okay who's your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it Ron
Ronda sanctimonious or meatball rock
well I can't but even he went off
meatball wrong I can't uh I don't know
how to spell the sanctimonious I don't
really know what it means but I don't
know what that is you're being like I'm
a little stupid she went to Yale shut up
you know how to spell it he's such like
a I'm just like I don't know nothing
about nobody oh look at me give me my
banjo let me shake the money yes
I'm just a humble girl hold on let me
get my false teeth in before I answered
yeah
bro what now wait where did didn't you
[__] like grow up and where did he
grow up he grew up in Tampa yeah he's
just like he's like an upper middle
class kid
[__] Yale and he's like yeah I'm I'm
I don't know nothing yeah I don't know I
never spelled nothing in my life Donald
Trump despite being like again a rich
liberal from New York is infinitely more
authentic as like a petty idiot right
then then Ron is he's authentic way
that's why he's so successful yeah I
always used to say like he is genuinely
disingenuous like he is a con man but
very not alive in the words of the great
George Costanza it's not a lie if you
believe it yeah and he is at that level
of delusion but meatball Ron he's such a
phony sanctimonious or meatball rock
yeah but even he went off meatball wrong
I can't uh I don't know how to spell the
sanctimonies I don't really know what it
means but I you know I kind of like it's
long it's got a lot of valve I mean so
we'd go with that yeah he's here's
Morgan you're really loving that huh so
he's giving he's giving the accurate
criticism though like that's why the
sanctimonious wasn't a good [__] rib
but you wasn't good keep saying it
though
uh Trump hasn't given up on it he keeps
going back yeah I don't know why the
sanctimonious I doesn't have the same
Riz it's just I don't know I don't know
y'all might be under you might be
downplaying Trump's genius here it might
come around to be something maybe all of
a sudden you're gonna see a bunch of
rednecks being like Ralph's to
sanctimonious it's like a fire and
brimstone the saint Damone yes slow I
mean being sanctimonious is annoying
like that's what literally it's like how
do you spell that as a big part of why
people hate liberals you know what I
mean they're so like sanctimonious look
at that mean
so maybe that's why he's identifying uh
him as that but that's a long word how
do you spell that fine you know you can
call me you can call me whatever you
want I mean just as long as you you know
also call me a winner
Wow
Mike drama he's just such a bad idiot
you can also call me a winner call me a
winner okay because I like encouragement
too I like positive reinforcement okay
we all feel a little bit insecure
sometimes I'm a winner
yeah okay
I just want to be left alone I just want
to be left alone man Ron the winner
maybe we could be calling him because
yeah Ron the coolest dude
Rhonda almost lost to Andrew Gillum by
like you know 0.25 percent
right
we should call them that what about uh
Ronald everyone rolls off the tongue
what about Ronald Weasley
that Harry Potter Ron
it's not working Ronald Weasley Little
Live someone in the chat someone in the
chest said Ron decriminalize underage
drinking
that is very Florida
that's a good one yeah yeah
here he is uh hosting drama alert Ron
the arbitrary nature of age of consent
laws
right on dry Miller drama alert
the sanctimonious the meatball ROM deep
State Ron it's right there just pluck it
hell just geyron Gay Ron what about what
about um what about um [__] what's it
called a good one is wrong
call him Rob no yeah calling him Rob he
did that Trump did that in a press uh
briefing dude he wrote Rob DeSantis just
call him the wrong name that's actually
kind of that's kind of good Rob hey Rob
what about l-rob elrond like elrond
Hubbard like science like e-rob sort of
oh e-rob wait is it which guy
and isn't Enron good isn't that's a good
Nick oh good nickname yeah uh it
requires too much you need to like know
things to like understand that that's
yeah
and being gay is bad so right that's why
I don't know if I don't know what he's
got he's got nothing I think he's wrong
nobody here he's gay as can be like
personally he's like Puss in Boots his
boots are cute don't get me in my
opinion his best Trump's best team was
pencil Nick Adam Schiff like he just
rolled oh pencil neck was there
you can't beat that no you can't beat
that that's why it does like someone
said it feels I don't know lost a step I
don't know why he's having such a hard
time yeah there's so many good ones
Pencil Neck that shit's genius seriously
I like that we're talking about this
like this this will uh you know this
will make it or break it for Trump's
chances in the primaries absolutely and
because of how [__] stupid the
Republican base is in general like that
kind of is true
Big Gay Ron over here he's big and gay
he's okay he's a gay guys he's gay
gay
he was on a gay occasion again everybody
came
um more Ron more Ron DeSantis are we we
always get this conversation always
turns into everybody trying to find
their best nickname just leave it up to
the Legends okay yeah I just I just
don't want to let us down man Rhonda
Sanders somebody said
he's like Bernie Sanders he's a
socialist he's a socialist listen to how
I say dissenters the problem with Ron is
that everything Ron does is basically
the same as Donald Trump so he can't
really hit him on like most of the uh
most of his policies right so he has to
in my opinion talk about how Ron wants
to be him
and you'll never be the number one I'm
number one believe me like if he said
that more and he'd be able to do that
more I think that's an effective
strategy to undermine Rob bottom Ron
he's beta
oh wait let's take one more look at uh
Marlo before we sign off okay it doesn't
look like the arrest will be happening
today of course it's the mid-afternoon
over there on the East Coast we can hear
the crickets chirping it's the noon the
sun is about to be going down here in a
few hours uh weather is looking decent a
little mild wind we're getting a nice
flow of the water there uh not so much
activity on the lawn how are we feeling
for tomorrow uh potentially it seems
like the arrest for tomorrow is imminent
Ethan it will happen anytime and any
place we don't know exactly when the
police are defunded like I already
mentioned because of the radical liberal
Democrats
and there are attitudes towards the
police however our brave boys in the
blue will inevitably come knocking down
Donald Trump's door
that's right uh Hassan absolutely and uh
you guys can see we're gonna keep
tracking there's that white pickup truck
if you go back to the shot there and the
the driveway there I'm wondering who is
whose car is that that uh Ford is that a
Chevy is that a GMC pretty sure that's
still the landscapers well it might be
the landscapers it may be double agents
it may be we need to know who the
everything going on in and out of there
because this is a secured location we're
talking about Secret Service we're
talking about potentially a federal
agents so there's a lot of ends and lots
of outs and we've got to keep track of
every little pixel that's moving on that
screen
they pointed out that it might be a
Bronco that might be the getaway car
oh it's a white Bronco so sick you know
um
I wish we could just run that live
stream that
but it's it's not gonna be worth it the
greatest all right thanks nice to see
you Hassan nice to see you too Ethan
great job with those animals you you did
a lot of nice things for Animals I try
on the lookout
still on the lookout for a pupper
for myself if somebody in the audience
has a puppy would you would you want
them to reach out or no
um maybe I mean I'm not I'm not cute if
it's ugly we're not interested yeah yeah
no ugly well
ugly dogs technically no dogs are ugly
I've seen ugly dogs
no I have I have no I'm sorry and I've
seen ugly babies too I do want oh you're
crazy the baby's just not they're you're
out of control
yeah okay that's true like I mean I'm
not a big fan of small dogs anyway but I
want a big dog I want a big boy I want a
puppy that'll be a a grow into a big boy
here one how about one of these oh God
okay all right all right all right all
right you proved your point this is
anti-dog propaganda we know there's like
a whole sub-genre of dog owners that
want their dog to look as ugly as
possible yeah they're called people who
buy pugs
I mean I've seen yeah fair enough but
I've seen where I've been bugs are cute
I gotta stand up for pugs a little bit I
know that they're like they are the
Abominations of God and humans they
should not live I have a half Chihuahua
half Pug so [__] you oh wow there you go
[__] you we have one in our ranks
okay well anyway
um thank you uh nice to be here
unfortunately there was no arrest today
but hopefully next time
it could happen next Thursday perhaps
I'm Gonna Keep I'm Gonna Keep uh track
of it on my own stream later as well in
a similar way not I'm not in the 20
billion dollar compound though so I
can't have the screen on screen that's
okay we have we'll next week we'll have
a helicopter overhead and that we'll be
able to give seems I've also broken the
camera
is it oh it's stuttering it's just I
think it's all good yeah
all right guys thank you so much we'll
be here tomorrow which is Friday
beautiful day after dark of course a
lovely beautiful day tomorrow
and uh we'll be here for that so thank
you guys everyone for watching Hassan
thank you for being here God bless
alhamdulillah
that's not your language
it's Arabic but I mean I I get it
Ramadan
[Music]